l tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sul nuovo
videogame con la crus trip praticamente
ragazzi videogioco che sto per fare è
diversissimo da ogni videogioco che ho
fatto finora ma ha uno scopo preciso
voglio vedere se mi viene da vomitare
sì questo in teoria ragazzi sarebbe
l'esperimento adesso capirete perché ok
perfetto ci siamo anche bello è rega
secondo me recami spunta winnie the pooh
da qualche parte però però vabbè
comunque ragazzi test di vomito numero
uno perfetto che allora ci siamo
che bello vi spiego un attimino piano
piano
no no no no no ecco perfetto siamo
partiti di merda vi spiego perché sennò
non si chiama ecco merda ok ok che il
piano piano piano che non capire la
femmina è va beh la madonna mi sono
scontrato contro qualsiasi cosa partenza
da dio
non che voleva spiegarvi nati cos'è
successo è morto un minuto di silenzio
per quel poverino che s'è suicidato
adesso
è un cervello dei primi che se sei un
ciclista cioè questo qui non chiedetemi
come faccio a vedermi anche se sono io
non lo so comunque va beh partiamo così
che è meglio la classe suicidata in
partenza non è una bella cosa vuol dire
che deve fare proprio schifo sto
tracciato che è perfetto
sì no sì un cazzo sono caduto a ciò
prova dai vai vai a possono fare ragazzi
non edificio ma questo era il primo
livello quello più facile
pensate gli altri che cazzo sono ma se
si sono morto ma per come faccia a
morire così ne vuoi capire la vuoi
andare avanti tu vai avanti tu se vuoi
però non erano ecco bra no mi dispiace
per quella povera per quel povero
cristiano però non è colpa mia se
mediago che mi son fermato al mic al v
piano piano piano non si bravo bravo zio
dove vado sto andando eva perché cazzo
sono più veloci ma ferrari bellissimo
raga comunque a parte gli scherzi sto
gioco è assurdo ragazzi sparatevi sarà
togliti dalle palle tu mi è piaciuto un
fiore all esperimento che volevo fare i
sto gioco sarebbe o mio dio che c'è
senso di vuoto bruttissimo brutti
orribile sta cosa mio dio io non volevo
fare il ciclista non è la mia
aspirazione per l'alba un albero c'era
uno stava dicendo ragazzi che non è che
sono proprio un ciclista nato quindi non
è che non è che sto andare bene in bici
e si vede
però la cosa che volevo provare il senso
di vomito pazzesco ma dico si può andare
si si si può andar via dio giusto andare
ragazze aiuto più stare calmi cos'è
minchiate va come faccio a farlo
leggermente paura di vedere posso andare
tranquillo senza morire ogni 4 secondi
tipo che cazzo fai
no no non andare là e va beh sono morto
anch'io io mi preoccupo ragazzi di non
saper andare in bici
[Musica]
ok faccio successo fermi l'attimo che
voglio andare a controllo è successo lì
socio 6 tutto a posto volta protetti
serve una corda tela lancio non so che
bello che sono io l'ho lasciata sopra e
non è che va bene bravo zio bravi
ragazzi
no no no no no no no padoan cosa mi sto
se ce l'ho fatta
o mio dio è una rampa che figo come
salgo su salito si ok ragazzi sono sono
su una rampa esattamente che io non so
andare in bici sono su delle rampe ok
calmo o dio mio dio solo morto può avere
un po di spinta se non ce la farò mai ti
passa parte sì sì perfetto ci ho fatto
ragazzi
mio dio cosa ho fatto devo andare sono
rimasto incastrato che bello no no no no
no no no no no no non hai capito un
cazzo della vita e via andare
dove vai vai vai sì o fatta credo e non
lo so piano zio piano che ci ammazziamo
piano piano io santis è ovvio
secondo voi mi sono fatto male perché
italia lega questo questo è il più
semplice o mio dio
cos'è ma sei serio o mio dio brega rega
merda e va bene va bene vogliamo né un
altro ragazzi perché questo proviamo
altri questo qua rosso bruttissimo che
fa paura solo a leggerlo cosa mi devo
aspettare di brutto di qua cazzo è
difficile già mi sono incastrato e
ascolta milioti oggi prendo attestato ti
muovi bra ecco vedi che le minacce
funzioni bravissimo cosi cosi carico ti
voglio naro gran forza forza o mio dio
mio dio
no no no no no no no no va beh sì ma
fare un precipizio un po più lungo non
lo so vai vai vai verneau all'albero ho
diviso non l'ho preso non ho preso però
qualcuno mi deve spiegare cosa amico mio
stai bene qualche buon anima che mi
spiega come fare sta parte senza morire
ammazzato ogni volta che è un po
difficile
non si capisce ma sì l'ho fatta ho fatto
ragazzi piano piano piano piano piano
mio addio qualcuno mi spiega come ha
fatto a farcela prima che è impossibile
se si è fatta di nuovo bravo bravo bravo
rallenta cazzo se ciò non sia una sexy
vabbè ma che le montagne russe sono più
sicure volevo vedere se mi veniva da
vomitare effettivamente mi viene da
vomitare ma più di quanto pensassi molto
di più devo tenere il freno
continuamente in st parti impossibile
ok buono così perfetto lavo bravo ok no
esattamente non è proprio una
scampagnata dalla nonna questa
sono vivo sono vivo non fate domande non
ne ho la più pallida idea mi sono
salvato il culo per un millimetro e sto
per morire questo per morire supremo di
a saper morire sto per morire
invece no invece invece sono un [ __ ]
i ragazzi a fosse volta che vado dal
panettiere ci vado in bici non potete
capire ragazzi il disagio di sto gioco
sul loculo swift è una roba pazzesca ma
[ __ ] sono di nuovo al punto di
prima a niente devo andare contro gli
alberi ma perché è contro gli alberi
arrivo prima io tanto
cosicché stato preso porca [ __ ]
ma se il serio un'altra strada che non
volevo prendere l'ho presa per sbaglio
vai vai vai vai sì sì ragazzi ce l'ho
fatta sono arrivato al punto di prima
non mi ricordo dove sono morto prima di
preciso non lo voglio sapere che bel
paesaggio che c'è qua
mio dio meglio che guardo avanti che non
si sa mai comunque complimenti per il
pedone che devo andare di preciso non mi
ricordo che io non so la strada dovrebbe
essere un parco dovrebbe essere un
percorso questo ma la strada non la so
se quella roba lì perché non si capisce
una rampa mio dio
se no sono arrivato ho vinto serio ho
vinto solo in una zona entrato in casa
se ho vinto mi sento la persona più
realizzata del mondo ma devo fare
retromarcia perché se non sbatte contro
la casa e muoio sì per questo gioco e
così i ragazzi non vi stupite no piano
bravo zio bravo non posso [ __ ] le
bici accordo ragazzine che posso che
concludere qui novi giorno sto morendo
cosa ciò ai capelli che mi guardate così
tanto a parte gli scherzi sto mi viene
da vomitare in una maniera che non avete
idea 20 ragazzi spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto spero per vecchi nomi
incontriate mai per strada con la bici
perché potrebbero essere cazzi
seriamente proprio et ragazzi spero che
il video vi sia piaciuto come se tra gas
e il video mi è piaciuto il sottomento
mi piace anche a fagiani facebook e come
non i video trovate una descrizione se
volessi distretti di civiltà non
prossimo vivo belle ragazze